爱马仕家族的八卦
比买一只铂金包要狗血多了
有候补名单
我想也是
5年
这可不是普通包包
它是铂金包
这句话让有着近两百年历史的爱马仕
一直走在奢侈品巅峰
而在这奢侈之巅背后的家族
却遭遇了一件非常荒谬的怪事
600万股的爱马仕股份
价值100亿欧元
消失了
这些股份的原持有人
是爱马仕的第五代继承人之一
尼古拉斯·皮埃奇
就在去年五月
他把自己的前财富顾问埃里克·弗雷蒙德
以及LVMH和他的董事长阿尔诺
一起告上了法庭
他怀疑 自己的顾问联合LVMH
给自己做了局
但这个很奇怪
要知道 爱马仕和LVMH这两家公司
没有什么业务往来
而且风格也很不一样
那么皮埃奇消失的600万爱马仕股票
是怎么和LVMH扯上关系的呢
更让人费解的是
这么一大笔钱
光是买Birkin都能装200多节高铁车厢
财富顾问再怎么捣鼓都得弄出点声响吧
那它们又是怎么从皮埃奇眼皮子底下
不翼而飞的呢
欢迎来到《硅谷101》 我是Yiwen
这期视频
我们来聊聊爱马仕家族的这桩奇案
这百亿欧元的巨额财富是怎么样消失的
顺便说一句 如果在这个过程当中
你发现LVMH横空插了一脚
那么没错 这笔巨款的消失
也涉及到了本世纪最大的奢侈品收购案
我们先来捋一下
这个巨额财产纠纷案的原告
尼古拉斯·皮埃奇到底是个什么来头
现年83岁的皮埃奇
母亲是爱马仕家族第三代掌门人
埃米尔·爱马仕（Émile-Maurice Hermès）的女儿
按照家族生意的传统套路
皮埃奇也曾在爱马仕做过高管
但不知道他是不喜欢还是不擅长
没多久他就离开了公司
之后他创立过自己的时装公司
做过滑水教练
到最后干脆什么事业也不搞
一心在欧洲乡下靠爱马仕的股份分红生活
那皮埃奇手里的股份现在到底有多少呢
1993年 出于让家族成员
能够用公允透明的价格交易股票的目的
爱马仕在巴黎泛欧证券交易所上市
尽管上了市
但庞大的爱马仕家族
依然保留了74%的股权
1996年 皮埃奇的母亲去世
他从母亲那里继承了近5%的股份
之后姐姐去世
他又从姐姐那里继承了大约1%的股份
这些股份加在一起
占到了爱马仕总股本的近5.8%
如果一切都没有发生
皮埃奇本来应该凭借它们
做着爱马仕最大的个人股东
而在去年11月底
也就是巴黎司法院
对于皮埃奇的诉讼做出庭审的时候
这笔股份的价值达到了上百亿欧元
皮埃奇确实也以为自己挺富有的
他在1998年前后就从法国移居到了瑞士
远离家族的管控
过着惬意的田园富豪生活
疫情的时候
他又和自己庄园里的一个摩洛哥园丁
处出了感情
说是在那段比较艰难的日子里
园丁对他照顾有加 双方相依为命
他把园丁 园丁的妻子
和他们的两个孩子当成自己的家人
还送给过他们超过50处房产
本来一切看上去都很美好
但就在2022年底
园丁妻子打了一次“小报告”
成为了打破皮埃奇财富美梦的“第一锤”
那年夏天
皮埃奇把他当时的财富顾问弗雷蒙德
叫到了他家 问对方说
我之前叫你给园丁家转100万瑞士法郎
你转得怎样了
当时弗雷蒙德就支支吾吾的
这个对话还被园丁的妻子在一旁听到了
弗雷蒙德走了以后
园丁的妻子就立马告诉皮埃奇
财富顾问撒谎了
我们根本没有收到过什么转账
听到这里 皮埃奇才觉得不对劲了
于是就告诉了一位朋友
这位朋友就告诉他说 你该做做审计了
于是皮埃奇就聘请了法律团队和咨询公司
对他的财务状况做了全面审查
这一审查才发现
他的账户早就空空如也
其中有90%的爱马仕股份
早在2008年就被转卖了
一气之下 皮埃奇解雇了弗雷蒙德
并且2023年在瑞士日内瓦
对弗雷蒙德提出诉讼
指控他犯了“大规模欺诈罪”
利用自己对他40年的友情
背着自己出售了巨额的爱马仕股份
弗雷蒙德是怎么做到
在不知不觉之间
卖掉皮埃奇那么多股份的
我们还得从他这个人
以及他这个财富顾问是怎么当上的讲起
1980年代 弗雷蒙德通过婚姻
进入了日内瓦最显赫的家族之一
他的岳父是某家私人银行的合伙人
在日内瓦的金融界享有很高的声望
弗雷蒙德因此进入了这家私人银行
并且由岳父引荐认识了皮埃奇
《华尔街日报》独家爆料过
在染指皮埃奇的财产之外
弗雷蒙德还有一些不太光彩的前尘往事
2010年时 他和他当时所在的公司
因为内部交易被罚款了400万欧元
在他的财富管理从业经历里
初代邦女郎乌苏拉·安德丝
以及一位已故的法国芭蕾舞演员
都指控过他有不当行为
但也不知道是皮埃奇没留意到这些消息
还是他和弗雷蒙德关系太好
皮埃奇还是选择了
毫无保留地相信弗雷蒙德
自从上个世纪90年代末搬到瑞士的时候
皮埃奇就委托弗雷蒙德
帮他安排了和财产相关的一切
弗雷蒙德的管理公司
基本上充当了皮埃奇的秘书处
会拆开他的信件 接听他的电话
签署他的支票
甚至教皮埃奇怎么跟爱马仕家族的人沟通
弗雷蒙德给皮埃奇的理由是
这样能让皮埃奇生活得更轻松
在各种委托关系里面最离谱的有两个
一个是空白文件
这意味着弗雷蒙德可以
在皮埃奇签过字的白纸上
填写任何数字和文字
再以皮埃奇的名义去做事
另一个让人意想不到的是
当初移居瑞士的时候
弗雷蒙德居然说服皮埃奇
把自己名下和其他爱马仕家族成员一样的
登记在各自名下的记名股票
改成了不记名股票
你可以说在瑞士这种富人的避税天堂
改成不记名股票能方便避税
但一旦把股票从记名改成不记名
也意味着追踪股权 发掘股权变动
几乎变得不可能了
事情到这一步稍微有了一些眉目
在无限信任下
皮埃奇听从弗雷蒙德的建议
把原本的记名股票改成了不记名股票
又在不知不觉间签署了大量空白文件
让弗雷蒙德悄悄转卖他的股票
成了可能的事情
不管你觉得皮埃奇大不大意
日内瓦法院反正是觉得他太马虎了
以至于在2023年
皮埃奇告弗雷蒙德的时候
法院驳回了这次诉讼
理由是皮埃奇对自己的财务状况漠不关心
在弗雷蒙德面前完全放弃了自己的控制权
导致法院没有理由介入
气急的皮埃奇也没有放弃
在他接连不断的诉讼和法院的调查中
600万爱马仕股票究竟如何消失的真相
浮出了水面
2024 2025两年
皮埃奇先后向法国司法部门
提出了对弗雷蒙德的民事诉讼和刑事诉讼
这个过程里 弗雷蒙德多次否认
他染指过皮埃奇的爱马仕股份
但在2025年的调查中 他最终承认
这些股份早在十多年前就被他出售
只不过皮埃奇对这些股权的转让完全知情
这一次 法官并没有完全相信
弗雷蒙德的辩解
因为皮埃奇也拿出了一些文件
显示弗雷蒙德曾经跟他保证过
他的财富是完好的
于是法官向弗雷蒙德提出了初步指控
罪名包括伪造文件 使用伪造文件
以及加重型滥用信任
他们还冻结了弗雷蒙德的银行账户
并且把他生平最爱的艺术画作 雕塑
和昂贵家具一并冻结
也许是知道自己注定要面临一个
无法翻盘的局面
弗雷蒙德在去年7月
接受完司法部门问询的两周后
在瑞士阿尔卑斯山的一个度假木屋附近
被一辆火车撞上 当场死亡
警方则判定他属于自杀
弗雷蒙德无疑是导致600万股爱马仕股份
凭空消失的关键人物
根据多方审计以及调查人员掌握到的文件
这些股票转让后的收益
有一部分被弗雷蒙德自己拿走了
弗雷蒙德沉迷于各种艺术品和奢侈品
不仅在瑞士日内瓦
有一个带艺术画廊的大房子
在意大利佛罗伦萨附近
还有一座摆满了艺术品的宫殿
弗雷蒙德还渗透了皮埃奇的律师
大家像提前通过气一样
告诉皮埃奇相同的话术
那就是爱马仕股份
还原封不动地躺在他的账户里
他甚至诱导了皮埃奇 教他如何减少
和爱马仕其他家族成员的电话沟通
如何在家人面前坚称自己仍然有巨额股份
更过分的是 皮埃奇手中的股份
的确在2008年时被卖掉了90%
那他账户里至少还剩下10%的股份
审计结果显示
这10%的股份在2013年底还值1.3亿欧元
但在这之后的10年 它们也全都消失了
甚至 在弗雷蒙德明明知道
皮埃奇的股份已经不复存在的情况下
他还试图把它们
卖给卡塔尔王室的一个投资机构
到这一步 我们也只能说
皮埃奇是纯纯信错了人
也有的观众要问了
90%的股份在2008年被卖了
那么是谁买走了这些股份呢
答案是
对爱马仕品牌一直虎视眈眈的LVMH
根据弗雷蒙德的说法
2001年6月 LVMH在日内瓦的一名员工
联系上了他
问他是否愿意参与一场合作
目标是建立对爱马仕的持股和投资
弗雷蒙德答应了对方的请求
于是在2008年时
弗雷蒙德将480万股爱马仕股份
转入了一个叫做Dilico的实体
这些股份随后又作为LVMH
股权互换的一部分
被转到了法国兴业银行
当初弗雷蒙德卖这些股份的时候
平均价格是每股86.66欧元
而现在 爱马仕的股价
已经超过了1600欧元
来 敲个黑板
大家记住我们刚才一直提到的
时间节点和关键词
2001年的试探 2008年的股份转移
股权互换和法国兴业银行
在我们接下来的讲述里
它们会串起另一个故事
告诉你皮埃奇消失的爱马仕股份
只是LVMH野心里的一环
皮埃奇无意之间被卷进了
本世纪奢侈品行业最大的商战里
而LVMH董事长阿尔诺的目标
则是吞下整个爱马仕
2010年10月23号
爱马仕当时的CEO帕特里克·托马斯
在阿尔卑斯山骑自行车的时候
突然接到了LVMH董事长阿尔诺的电话
阿尔诺告诉他
LVMH已经持有爱马仕17%的股份
托马斯后来跟媒体回忆过
自己当年的第一反应是
这根本不是在法国做生意的方式
那阿尔诺是谁
他从一个小小地产商做起
靠收购迪奥有了第一个奢侈品品牌
之后一点点入主LVMH
后来还差点买下Gucci
他就是奢侈品圈的“华尔街之狼”
才不会管在法国做生意是什么方式
这通电话打完两小时后
LVMH就发布公告
说集团持有1501.6万股爱马仕股票
占爱马仕总股本的14.2%
而它手里还有一份
价值300万股爱马仕股份的互换合约
到10月26日 合约兑现后
LVMH再次宣布 它手中的爱马仕持股
占到了对方总股本的17.1%
我们在梳理皮埃奇财富来源的时候说过
爱马仕在1993年上市的时候
把74%的股份留在了家族成员的手里
并没有进入公开市场
而且金融行业也有严格的规定
当一家公司持有另外一家（公司）
超过5%的股票的时候就要公开披露
那LVMH是怎么在一夜之间
把那么多爱马仕的股票搞到手的呢
首先 LVMH对爱马仕的觊觎
早就不是一天两天的事了
因为爱马仕在奢侈品行业
有绝对的顶尖定位
每年都在稳定增长
而且盈利能力
比其他奢侈品品牌高出一大截
所以早在阿尔诺还没有入主LVMH的时候
后者的高管就商量过
要不要买一些爱马仕的股票
后来阿尔诺上任
越来越喜欢在奢侈品圈买买买
对于爱马仕的兴趣更是有增无减
他还曾经通过媒体公开表态
说就竞争对手而言
有两家公司让我钦佩
香奈儿以及爱马仕
从2001年开始
LVMH真的把这种喜欢付诸实践了
第一个阶段 2001到2002年
LVMH通过设立卢森堡的子公司
直接在公开市场购入少量爱马仕股份
2002年 LVMH再设立美国子公司
继续购入
随后 美国子公司手上的股份被拆分
转移到三家巴拿马公司手上
2006年 爱马仕进行了一比三的拆股
使得LVMH对爱马仕的总持股数
达到了530万股
但这个时候 总持股的比例不到5%
第二个阶段是2006年12月开始
爱马仕发生高管层变动
传奇CEO让-路易·杜马斯卸任
LVMH认为这是绝佳的时机
可以进一步增持爱马仕股份
于是他们委托投行罗斯柴尔德进行规划
这在内部被称为Project Mercury
“水星计划”
这个计划最终的结论是
爱马仕的股权分散在各个家族成员手上
只要你能找到家族的合作方
那么爱马仕股权的整个平衡结构
就会被改变
而在“水星计划”的基础上
有另外的银行机构
给LVMH想了更一个歹毒的“损招”
关键词是股权互换
这个股权互换简单来说
就是一种基于某个指定时间的
股票价格的赌局
打个比方 赌局双方是A和B
赌的是现价100美元的A公司
在一年后股价会不会上涨
A赌的是涨 B赌的是跌
如果一年后A公司股价涨到了120美元
那么B赌输了 需要支付给A 20美元
如果一年后A公司股价降到了70美元
那么A赌输了 需要给B 30美元
这原本是一个不需要持有股票
又能让赌局双方享有股价涨跌权益的
金融衍生工具
但LVMH却在对爱马仕的这场股权兑换中
把这场对赌游戏升级了
要和LVMH玩这个对赌游戏的机构
需要真的去买爱马仕的股票
如果到了某个时间节点
爱马仕的股价上涨了
对方并不用支付给LVMH股价上涨的差价
而是要把手中的爱马仕股票转让给LVMH
后者会支付给他们当初购买股票的费用
以及一笔手续费
当然 如果爱马仕的股价跌了
LVMH则会愿赌服输
支付股价的下跌缺口
这个股权互换的法子
对于LVMH想要隐匿收购爱马仕来说
可是太实用了
首先按照监管规定
对于上市公司持有股份超过5% 10%
和15%这些关键比例的时候
必须在4个交易日内披露
但股权互换是一种金融衍生品
不到合约到期那天就构不成实际持股
LVMH完全可以在
不触发披露义务的情况下积累大量股份
其次 股权互换属于场外衍生品
交易信息没有那么公开透明
监管机构很难实时监测
LVMH也完全可以通过找多家银行
分散操作来规避监管
在实际操作中
LVMH分别找到了三家银行
和他们完成这个股权互换
它们分别是法国外贸银行
手中有500万股爱马仕股票
占到总股本的4.7%
法国兴业银行
手中有480万股爱马仕股票
占总股本4.5%
东方汇理银行
手中有320万股爱马仕股票
占总股本3%
因为这些持股都是在举牌线以下
所以都没有触发监管
而且 LVMH是等到2010年6月
爱马仕的传奇CEO杜马斯患绝症去世以后
才和三家机构谈判
把原本股权互换中的现金结算
换成股票实物结算的
这个时间 很显然
是爱马仕最脆弱的时间点
只能说商战实在是太残酷了
而根据司法部门的调查
前面我们提到的
爱马仕继承人皮埃奇的
前财富顾问弗雷蒙德
在2008年 把480万股爱马仕股份
转到了某个实体里
这些股份随后作为LVMH
股权互换的一部分
被转到了法国兴业银行
而这笔股份的数字
刚好就和法国兴业银行
同LVMH签订的协议对上了
说到现在
消失的爱马仕股份终于被找到了
但这个时候
LVMH手里已经有了17%的爱马仕股份了
但爱马仕家族当然也不是吃素的
于是立刻开始了反击
到了这个时候
爱马仕家族内部拉响了红色警报
这些家族后人手里
确实持有超过七成的集团股票
但这些股票散落在世界各地的
200多个家族成员手里
每个人手里的股权都不算多
而当时LVMH手里已经有17%的股份了
要是它再想办法去这些人手里收点
那进入爱马仕的董事会
甚至最后收购爱马仕 都是有可能的事
不过野蛮人打到家门口
当务之急是先把LVMH赶走
爱马仕家族的做法也是既团结又干脆
2010年12月
在几十名主要家族股东的支持下
新CEO托马斯重新设计了股权结构
以防外来者的恶意收购
2011年12月
这些家族成员召开了秘密会议
同月 一个名叫H51的
爱马仕家族控股公司成立
爱马仕的家族成员们从未如现在一般团结
他们把手中合计50.2%的股份
都托管给了H51
并对股份的出售和转让做了严格的规定
首先 这些股份在20年内都不能被出售
而为了让掏出真金白银
支持公司的家族成员能够衣食无忧
爱马仕在之后的很多年里
每年都有高额的股息回报
其次 除了注入H51的股份之外
家族成员们还保留了大概12.6%的股份
H51对这些股份享有优先购买权
防止股份被外部资本吞噬
到H51正式成立的时候
这场收购大战的局面已经很凶险了
当时LVMH对爱马仕的股份
已经从2010年的17.1%增加到了23.2%
市面上仍在流通的爱马仕股票不到8%
那么这场收购大战又是如何收尾的
其实组建H51的时候
法国金融市场监管机构AMF
算是帮了个小忙
按照道理 一家公司持有另一家公司
超过30%的股权
如果还想继续增持
就必须向所有股东
发出收购全部股份的全面收购要约
但爱马仕这时候的局面是
它有超过20%的股份在LVMH手里
对方肯定不会轻易放手
于是爱马仕向AMF申请了豁免
对方也批准了
让H51无需发起全面收购要约
也能控制爱马仕超一半的控股权和投票权
得以暂时把阿尔诺堵在门外
到了2013年 AMF又以违反信息披露规则
刻意隐瞒增持爱马仕股份的真实情况为由
对LVMH处以800万欧元的罚款
时间再到2014年9月
互相告了两年的爱马仕
和LVMH达成了和解协议
LVMH同意放弃它持有的
绝大部分爱马仕股份
并承诺未来5年内
不会再收购爱马仕的任何股份
而它放弃爱马仕股份的方式
则是把这些股票通过特别派息分配给股东
其中就有8.48%的股份
派给了迪奥和阿尔诺的两个家族公司
2017年7月 LVMH披露
这三家被派到爱马仕股份的公司
对爱马仕的最大一笔持股已经降到了1.7%
它以后也不会再披露对爱马仕的持仓
当然 LVMH搞这么大阵仗
也不可能是空忙一场
虽然被罚款了800万欧元
但随着爱马仕股份的逐年上涨
LVMH大概从这笔收购战中
获得了34到38亿欧元的总资本收益
轰轰烈烈的收购大战到这里就结束了
可能观众还有一个疑惑
弗雷蒙德当初在承认卖股票的时候说过
皮埃奇是知情的
那么皮埃奇究竟是
完全不知道这些暗箱操作
还是在揣着明白装糊涂呢
其实在H51成立的时候
皮埃奇就有过一丝诡异的举动
当时那么多家族成员
你一点我一点地凑股票
皮埃奇却是唯一一个没有签署协议
也没有把股份交给H51托管的家族继承人
但皮埃奇对此的辩解是
每个人的自由
就是我们家族长久团结的最好保证
甚至 由于皮埃奇手里的股票
早就换成了无记名股票
就连爱马仕的管理层
也是2011年皮埃奇接受媒体采访后
才知道他手里还有6%的爱马仕持股
而为了搞清楚皮埃奇有没有
把这笔巨额股票卖给LVMH
爱马仕的管理团队还和他有过多次交涉
一个在2018年告诉过法官
自己曾经亲自多次核实过
自己的爱马仕持股没问题的人
为什么直到2022年
才发现自己的财产不翼而飞了呢
这实在是太奇怪了
当然 一切都可能是
弗雷蒙德在一味地哄骗皮埃奇
教他如何搪塞家族成员
教他如何应付法官
如今 自己的账户里
一份爱马仕股份都没有的皮埃奇
会不会后悔当时自己多次向别人保证过的
自己的财富没问题呢
经历了凶险的恶意收购之后
爱马仕的家族成员又在2022年
成立了统一的家族办公室Krefeld
如果说H51是保证爱马仕
不会再被他人侵犯的“盾”
那Krefeld就是管理并增值家族财富的“矛”
这个机构直到2024年才开始正式运行
目前的投资项目包括法国保险公司Albingia
还和KKR一起入股了健康美容集团
Anjac Health & Beauty
根据彭博亿万富翁指数
随着爱马仕业绩的持续坚挺
爱马仕超100名家族继承人的合计净资产
达到了1860亿美元
继续延续着他们
“欧洲最富有家族之一”的地位
但皮埃奇的日子当然就不一样了
去年八月 爱马仕现任杜马斯证实
公司曾经的最大个人股东
尼古拉斯·皮埃奇
已经不再持有公司股份
如今皮埃奇手里只剩下少量现金
和无法被动用的投资
去年年底 有人在去伦敦的廉价航空上
看到了这位曾经的亿万富翁
没错 他不但坐的是廉价航空
而且是机舱里没人会喜欢的
一排座位中既不靠窗 又不靠过道的
最中间的那个座位
跟着亿万富翁坐财富过山车的故事
到这里就要结束了
曾经有投资人说过
如果想要让资产升值
你要么持有爱马仕的包包
要么持有爱马仕的股份
但如今 就连爱马仕的股票也难言坚挺
4月15日 爱马仕发布最新财报
在全球经济放缓
奢侈品行业叫苦不迭之际
它今年第一季度的销售额
下滑1.4% 至40.70亿欧元
低于市场预期
财报发布当天
爱马仕的股价在盘中一度暴跌14%
创下了它史上最大盘中跌幅
好了 以上就是这期视频的全部内容了
大家的点赞、留言和转发
是我们《硅谷101》
做好深度科技和商业内容的最佳动力
我们下期再见